[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
est-ce que déjà les les grandes stars
comme ça un peu comme bah comme chacun
va tout à chacun chez le coiffeur est-ce
qu'elle se confie un peu c'est le moment
où elle parle elle vous raconte des
choses et le côté un peu secret médical
ouais bien sûr et c'est un moment où
elle se confie et c'est aussi parfois un
moment où elle se confie pas ou elle
reste aussi dans le silence elle besoin
aussi de de ce justement de se relâcher
avant de avant de je sais pas moi par
exemple de franchir le tapis rouge
parce que c'est donc c'est aussi un pour
elle aussi un moment de détente donc en
fait non on s'adapte ou si elle décide
de parler bah on on parle avec elle et
si on préfère rester dans le silence on
reste dans le silence alors allons-y
au-delà il vaut mieux pas parler hein
souvent des motos des motos taxi et des
motosaxis là ce qu'ils disent souvent la
plus désagréable du pape c'est un tel le
plus sympa c'est un tel alors c'est qui
la personne peut-être la moins la moins
le plus compliqué à coiffer on va dire
j'ai dit que je balance pas
il y a pas il y a pas forcément de de ou
pas parfois c'est un peu plus compliqué
ça peut être aussi des américaines mais
ça peut être aussi des françaises mais
c'est qui
en fait tu as le droit de dire une
personne avec qui
je me suis passé avec personne
elle est exigeante
j'adore ces mots comme un connard le
métier on dirait il est exigeant c'est
un gros con mais c'est vrai que je l'ai
dit moi je l'ai déjà coiffé ça c'est
toujours très bien passé avec elle je
l'ai coiffé quelques fois mais par
contre j'ai vu parfois effectivement des
des maquilleuses avec qui ça s'est pas
très bien passé avec question c'est les
stars qui choisissaient même de se
coiffer ou c'est vous qui indiquez le
truc où il y a un conseiller qui dit je
veux qu'elle ait un ou c'est vous qui
est totalement libre quand vous
travaillez avec une star de ce niveau là
alors en fait ça dépend c'est à dire que
si elle est habituée à ce qu'on la
coiffe régulièrement elle nous fait
entièrement confiance et on peut lui
faire des propositions et à ce moment-là
ah ouais elle se laisse faire tu
connaissais d'habitude voilà on connaît
ses habitudes et puis généralement
généralement elle se connaissent aussi
très très bien les femmes avec leurs
cheveux quand même c'est compliqué à peu
près ce qui
nous va il y a quelques petites
exigences
elles savent pertinemment ce qu'ils lui
vont ce qui ne leur va pas et et
l'hygiène même les stages
j'ai une question qui est presque un peu
personnelle il y a Christophe Willem qui
a beaucoup de stars
des implants vous voyez venir et pour ça
que je dis c'est un peu personnel il l'a
déclaré dans voici cette semaine et ils
sont de plus en plus à le déclarer à ne
pas le cacher est-ce que ma question
c'est est-ce que les implants se
coiffent comme des cheveux normaux ou
est-ce que c'est un travail différent
est-ce que vous appréhendez ça autrement
non alors c'est exactement comme des
cheveux normaux il y a une fois que
c'est implanté que ça repoussé c'est
vraiment alors sauf que Fabien il y a
plein de stars et d'animateurs qui
souvent quand ils ont des implants
viennent avec leur coiffeurs et
détestent qu'on touche leurs cheveux
parce qu'il nous faut les planquer oui
mettre des poudres parce qu'il y a des
trous les poudres sont beaucoup beaucoup
c'est quoi l'endroit le plus insolites
où vous ayez coiffé quelqu'un c'est pas
forcément dans un dans un coin salon
maintenant c'est en plus c'est un peu
d'actualité en ce moment et dans un
avion dans un jet
au Festival de Cannes et on m'a demandé
d'aller chercher une actrice qui faisait
un qui tournait en Italie et donc je
suis parti dans l'avion et on a atterri
directement à Cannes pour qu'elle puisse
monter les marches directement sauf que
là je me retrouve quand même dans un
c'était un petit jet j'ai complètement
étriqué j'avais pas d'électricité pas
d'eau rien de grave
faisait un petit trajet donc elle a pas
c'est pas
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs je
m'étais il y avait pas d'eau dans
l'avion
quelle est la coupe la plus originale
qu'on vous ai demandé qu'une ça vous est
demandé de faire celle de Sophie Davant
peut-être c'est la même depuis 30 ans
vous auriez peut-être le couple de
coiffure de coiffure
c'est une bonne question et honnêtement
j'aurais pas vous répondre là par
exemple un steak de viande comme Lady
Gaga ou un truc comme ça à fixer dans
les cheveux quelque chose de
complètement extravagant
et on est d'accord que
les vedettes chaudes qui ont une grande
cicatrice entre les deux oreilles c'est
un plan qui ont raté
d'un centimètre on rase ensuite on
découpe et on te les replante
depuis 20 ans ça repousse pas hein
j'aimerais vous passer des images alors
on va jouer un petit jeu et vous nous
direz si c'est naturel ou pas naturel un
plan pas un plan perruque
papyrusie rajoute alors on l'a essayé du
couplement 3 jours après la priori elle
parfois elle utilise des perruques elle
elle le dit elle le dit hein
Monica Bellucci mais des perruques
des petites bandes derrière toi non moi
j'ai rien du tout ouais c'est naturel
moi j'ai les cheveux à l'italienne mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de femmes
qui le font et ça ça donne plus de
glamour alors la suivante
c'est beaucoup de gens qui disent qu'il
a il a un petit toupet ou un truc non
non
mais je pense qu'il a rien il a rien du
tout
de Macron jeune
il y a un plan là il y a quoi Matt
Pokora voilà il y a un plan il y a un
plan bah vous avez vu comment appeler
mobile allô
[Applaudissements]
apparaître comme un spécialiste mais le
côté champ de poireau quoi le côté toc
toc toc toc
lui il a un côté Chambord
sexuellement
[Rires]
non parce que tu es en train de me dire
coloriste ça va maintenant tu es à fond
sur la coiffure vas-y alors ah bon non
j'ai un truc à vous dire que très très
intéressant c'est le nouvel mode restez
bien avec nous je vous tire dans un
instant comment il faut être coiffé si
vous voulez choper peu importe là
aujourd'hui hein ça c'est un glyphen
exactement et après on parlera c'est un
petit moment moins gai mais des stars et
la maladie pardon des stars oui de la
maladie mais pour l'instant on va rester
avec le coiffeur à tout de suite ou plus
drôle pour le moment Fabien Provost est
avec nous le coiffeur des stars
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
exigeante on a fait quelques petites
photos on a regardé des stars qui avait
des implants par des implants des
moumoute pas des perruques tout ça on se
moque pas on essaie de dire à la ménager
que quand vous arrivez vous avez les
cheveux comme ça et tout bah nous c'est
pas nous les stars c'est pareil mais que
voilà elles sont bien entourées il y
avait une question très brillante
d'ailleurs qui me dit qu'on avait pu
parce que je peux poser une question un
confinement depuis le début de la saison
ça fait du bien c'est vrai ça fait du
bien quand tu me dis des gentils laisse
les choses revenir doucement
si vous aviez déjà refusé de coiffer des
personnes soit parce que en terme
d'image ça me correspondait pas à
l'image que vous les représenter ça
m'intéresse de savoir si vous avez déjà
refusé des questions soit parce qu'elles
étaient sales
oui ça m'est déjà arrivé mais ils l'ont
jamais su bien
il y a des personnalités qu'on m'a
demandé d'aller coiffer ou j'ai dit que
je ne pouvais pas parce que parce que je
connaissais de réputation ou bien le
caractère ou bien effectivement d'autres
problèmes et donc du coup oui ça m'est
arrivé ils l'ont jamais su
mais tu sais que tu sais que d'ailleurs
je raconte mais je dis pas où parce que
j'ai pas de problème mais Benoît il sait
Marine Le Pen allait se faire faire une
couleur dans un coiffeur dans le 92 et
effectivement c'était un coiffeur un peu
connu tout ça vous connaissez et voilà
et forcément ça peut gêner un petit peu
des gens qui sont enfin dans le salon
pour du chiffre d'affaires et tout ça et
donc il les prenait systématiquement
dans une pièce à part et tu connais
et c'est c'est oui ça peut être
compliqué quand même d'avoir encore une
fois des gens qui sont clivants dans un
dans un salon ou dans un pour la
clientèle bon nous nous on est là
pourquoi faire on n'est pas là pour
faire de la politique ou savoir si c'est
l'actrice et à précieux ou pas apprécié
nous on est là pour pour rendre un
service et voilà nous on est là pour
mettre les gens en avant vous ou quoi
faire à gauche et à droite complètement
une coupe pour une star est-ce que vous
gonfler vos tarifs ou pas non alors les
il y a pas de de tarifs c'est-à-dire que
nous quand elles viennent se faire
coiffer au salon et que je les coiffes
c'est c'est une prestation
d'une cliente lambda avec le tarif du
salon
de 45 euros
vraiment mais allez-y on peut même pas
venir moi je m'en fous du tout naturel
il y a pas de couleur il y a rien alors
mais qui autour de la table à une
coiffure un peu ringarde on va revoir
enfin moderniser moi je suis heureux
[Rires]
je suis pas sûr d'Isa parce qu'elle est
très jolie je pense qu'ils a non non je
trouve que non c'est bien attention
non non j'ai vu pire
[Rires]
mais en revanche j'ai jamais fait de
couleur ni rien parce que mes copines
quand on dit elles sont très jeunes
elles ont des cheveux gris à partir de
25 ans
alors ici on a quoi là alors
je trouve que c'est beau c'est voilà
c'est un petit côté effectivement à la
barre d'eau c'est pas mal de tête en
valeur mais en même temps elle est jolie
donc elle peut tous se permettre c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
ici je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
depuis 10 minutes de l'émission on les
appelle ça à côté on a laissé Williams
[Rires]
ils sont ici c'est vrai on est allé
Williams
[Applaudissements]
deux jolies filles à côté ensemble
[Musique]
niveau coiffure
donc oui bah aussi tu vois
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que la mode la frange il faut
être très jolie comme Sophie mais la
frange c'est une fille ça peut être ça
peut être compliqué quand même ça peut
être compliqué ça peut être très
compliqué
les franges sur lorsqu'on a un petit
front
d'accordé chaque fois qu'elle faisait
refaire une de ses filles changer de
coiffure comme ça si quelqu'un vous dit
oh vous avez quelque chose de changé
dans le visage et tout vous dites c'est
la coiffure c'est pas la faute
intéressante mais pourquoi tu dis que
Madame Claude
j'ai fait un 52 minutes pour TF1 sur
Madame
oh non j'ai eu peur ouais c'était pas le
savoir
elle m'a dit qu'elle m'aurait bien aimé
dans sa bande elle me dit parce que moi
vous les aurez fait rire
vexé mais ça m'a vexé pas du tout tu es
très jolie tu les têtes donc là dessus
par là-dessus encore Jackie les plus
beaux cheveux une question de positive
il y en a pas mal mais là celle qui
vient en tête j'ai coiffé Eva Longoria
je pourrais qu'elle avait des très beaux
cheveux alors deux questions et après on
ira sur la tendance j'ai promis la
tendance notamment pour les hommes vous
allez voir ce qu'il faut faire elle fait
tout le temps faire ses pubs pour ses
racines ses couleurs parce que je le
vaux bien etc est-ce que vous est-ce
qu'elle est fait vraiment chez elle les
couleurs avec la boîte et les gorge
dans la cuisine
[Rires]
et de l'alu avec le bol la bassine et le
truc non non mais non tu sais quoi et
ben Sophie Marceau ne bouffe pas du
Marange non plus je te le dis bah non
non non non les gens qui t'annoncent des
choses c'est pas vrai alors
la tendance homme en ce moment est-ce
que vous savez ce que c'est c'est les
cheveux un peu sales un peu underground
il faut raser la
parade ici un peu dégradé un peu comme
les footballeurs non mais sur le dossier
comme ça
exactement
c'est le cheveux gris
ant je suis super à la mode ou c'est
juste pour les gars
mais toi tu as fait un truc génial c'est
que tu as gardé même coupe même couleur
depuis 60 ans ce qui fait qu'en fait tu
sais bien qu'il y a un moment avec la
roue qui tourne tu seras dans la tu vois
tu auras des élèves galère désolé de
galère et puis des bonnes années
[Applaudissements]
comme un mouton j'avais ça j'ai envoyé
une photo d'ailleurs à la prod j'avais
ça c'est vrai ah tiens des photos photos
de la prod très bonne idée regarde bien
on a une photo de parce que bon il y a
des catastrophes capillaires
notamment Sophie
Sophie ça va venir un jour Sophie ah je
vous ai pris je vous attendiez pas ah
voilà oh mon dieu
t'envoie une photo d'elle hyper belle et
montrer pas je suis moche
en plus j'ai pris 400 g cette semaine là
l'étoile d'araignées et là on a rien
aussi
est-ce que je peux monter une dernière
photo parce que j'aimerais votre avis là
j'ai tout de suite notamment un
spécialiste enfin je veux dire ce qui
m'a dit après jamais comment ta photo de
Donald Trump
vous vous souvenez qu'il avait fait une
émission de télévision en deuxième
partie de soirée il avait dit à
l'animateur tirez-moi les cheveux vous
verrez c'est pas une moumoute lorsqu'il
avait été élu voilà et ça peut pas
passer
exceptionnel mais c'est vrai je pense
qu'il avait pas de il avait pas de
moumoute c'est vrai et il devait
certainement ramener les cheveux les
faire un brushing les crêper un peu
enfin c'était d'accord il y avait
forcément un coiffeur dans l'histoire
oui ça oui mais bon on m'a vraiment dit
que c'était vraiment noumoute
merci beaucoup Fabien pour toute famille
[Applaudissements]